[Music]
Uh, let's go over how to get up from the
roll.
Okay, so we already did all the other
stuff. Uh, I'm just going to
roll. This is how I get up. My hips are
going to be lower than my shoulder.
There's no more inertia going that way.
I step up and I'll move back into hanmi.
Okay, I'll do it
again.
Boom. Into hanmi. Okay, let's try that.
All right. So, uh, in the first clip I
noted like there's no more
inertia going that way before you come
up. And so, to be clear, my h I will
take a four-point
stance and my hands will stay on the mat
until that inertia leaves. Okay? So, it
it would it's looking like this. You
going to watch how my
hands stay on the mat. Inertia left.
Then I came
up. Inertia left. Then I came up. I
don't want to
use momentum to come up like that. Okay.
Uh the reason
being you roll that way and use your
momentum to come up.
Okay. If I got
thrown, why do I want to focus on the
nagg? Because that's teaching me that's
the threat and we don't break obs on the
threat. You just you don't ever do that.
Okay? So, if I'm still the threat, he
survived the throw. He goes to do that,
he does that, and you're going to get
him very easily. Okay?
So you don't want to get
up fast or
easily. You get up when you can. And you
have to assess first whether you can get
up or not. Okay? And that if I have to
assess, I'm going to assess from the
most stable neutral position that I can.
And transitioning from gdedon up to
jodon is not a neutral position because
I am generating
inertia on top of the roll. So we don't
do you never seek height when someone's
charging at you. You have to be clear of
that attack before you actually seek
height. So all the inertia is gone.
Hands stay on the mat and the movement
from here to Han me is totally
uh done under your complete power.
There's no inertia that's assisting you
to get there. Okay, we'll try it again.
So here would be my naga. Okay. And he
would throw me that way. And my eyes are
on him the entire time. So I don't look
this way. I don't look down. I'm going
to all always look look at him as I do
my roll. Always looking at him. My head
turns really quick when I when I do
that.
Okay, really quick. When I do that,
okay, let's bring that
in. All right. when you get up, you are
already uh vectoring your mass, your
young aspect onto your midfoot and it is
very much like a back squat at that
point. Um so a drill that I like to do
because even here today I have people
that are using some inertia or have the
inertia shift their weight to their
heels. Let's say Andor has the inertia
shift their weight to their heels. And
this is just not marshially viable. So
we do the other this drill to to uh get
us aware of what's happening to our body
with this inertia. So I will do the
roll. Uh he will come in while I'm in
this position. He'll come in and I will
just pick him
up. We'll do it again. We're here. He
comes in and I will pick him
up again. He comes
in and I will pick him
up. Okay. I'm not trying to throw him.
I'm just letting him off my shoulder at
the end. All right. Try. So, I'll better
uh describe the drill. We haven't done
it in a while. Taylor forgot it. All the
UK does is just keep walking towards the
person. He stopped on me on that first
rep. Some of you were stopping on each
other, but he just walks towards me,
over me, and I'm
up. Okay.
Again, right here, he walks towards me,
and I'm
up. Okay. If I was on my heels, when he
walked towards me, he'd knock me back.
Okay? That's why he has to keep walking.
He would expose the heel weight. Okay,
try it again.
Andrew's going to roll. Let's go ahead.
Go ahead. Good. We'll do it again from
that side.
We'll do it again from that
side. Use that line. Please stop. Use
that line right there.
Go
again. Okay. You can see how he's going
in. He's rolling inwardly. On the first
rep where he didn't have the line, it
was even more pronounced. Now he has the
line and he realizes, "Oh yeah, Sensei
don't like us rolling inwardly, so I'm
going to fix myself." Why don't you fix
yourself without me here? Right. Okay.
What I want you to do is you see that
line? You're going to roll with your
hips going north. So that would be to
your right. You're not going to even
roll straight this time.
Go. There you go. and
again and
again. Okay, so that's the drill I would
like for you all to do in this uh in the
small forward roll.
Okay, we already
know that the closer my hips, the
vertical vector of my hips is to the
vertical vector of my
shoulders, then I'm going to have more
stacking of mass. I'm going to have more
mass at impact with the
mat. Mass times acceleration equals
force. Therefore, I'm going to have more
force at contact with the mat.
The longest or the furthest distance I
can have between the shoulder vertical
plane and the hip vertical plane is the
one you see right now. The length of my
spine. If we tuck, I just brought my
hips closer to my
shoulders. We don't want to do that
because that's going to stack mass.
That's going to increase mass, increase
force at impact.
One of the things that is getting you is
you're stuck in in the
somersaulting. This in Japanese this is
maui. There's there's no reference to
rolling or somersaulting in that
phrase. But you want to somersault. So
you want to
talk. We don't want a
somersault.
Ideally, this is be the least stacked
mass I could ever have. So, the closer I
get to
that, the from higher I could be thrown
and still not have that great a force at
impact. Secondarily, aside from the
somersault, you have this preoccupation
with how to stand.
Okay. So, you're what you're doing is
you're keeping your feet on the hip
vertical
plane. It'll look like this. Okay? So,
I'm on this line and I keep my
feet on that line.
If in that effort my knees go towards my
face, I'm going to bring the tailbone
into a tucked position and I'm going to
cause all the problems we just
said. In the X pattern, my legs will go
like
this. They will not be able to stay
where my hips are. They they can't do
it. So, usually what
happens when we throw someone who's
trying to tuck their legs, leave them on
the hip vertical
plane, they will flip in the air and
land just solidly on the hipbone. They
kind of do like a a sit when they get
flipped in the air. Okay. Um, you have
to not resist nor assist the technique.
So as your legs are going out with the
centrifugal energy, you should let your
legs go
out. So rather than have my feet on this
hip vertical plane marked noted by this
line, my feet go that way as if I was
trying to do
this. So watch how my feet logo in our
dojo. That's north. So that's west. My
feet will go
west. Almost like I'm trying to step on
that wall over
there. I will still find my feet.
Exactly like before, meaning I'm
standing. I will still have no inertia
when I get up and I'm still able to have
resist somebody that's coming on me and
be able to pick them up. Okay. So, let's
get our feet, our legs to come out and
get our knees and our and our leg mass
off the hip vertical plane.
So, training is always
progressionbased.
Um, okay. Can we make sure they're both
on? Is it That's the batteries. Press
stop, please. All right. Listen very
closely.
you training has to be
progressionbased. No beginner should
ever come in and
do all that you can do. It's just if if
that is
possible, then you're not doing all you
can
do. It has to be so inevitable in your
mind. Like today is Tuesday. I know for
a fact tomorrow is Wednesday.
is inevitably Wednesday
tomorrow. It is
inevitably impossible for the beginner
to do what I can
do. Therefore, what they're being taught
is what they can
do. What they're being taught then is
not the end
all or the once and for all. They have
to let go of what they've been shown in
order to continue to
progress, not
said
diplomatically. If we're doing math,
this is like, you're really dumb. I'm
going to have to teach you how to count
first. Counting is not the whole of
math. We moved on. Now, there's not even
any numbers in our freaking equations. I
can't have you freaking out over where
the all the numbers are and how come
three isn't after two right now. This is
let
go. So, when we first learn the forward
roll, the biggest difficulty for the
person is the hip vertical plane.
They will constantly roll
around the knee and the
foot and roll onto their
side. The reason for this is when the
uncultivated
mind is spiral
rotated, it goes
into a
confoundedness. It loses where it is in
space.
It's I say it's there's a moment of
unconsciousness in the middle of the
role. The
desi knows where they are at the
beginning of the role and knows where
they are at the end of the role but has
no awareness of what happened to them in
the middle of the role.
And so they are
unaware of how their hip came out of
that vertical plane and how they came
about rolling on their
side. We can go to Adam's video. In
Adam's video, he has what appears to be
a
recently new or relatively new Iikidoka.
And you see her doing exactly this. Her
hip comes out of the vertical plane of
the the quad, knee, foot, and she ends
up rolling on her side.
She is thereby. The problem with this is
when she does this, she does not
generate the bottom apex nor is she able
to pass the bottom apex on the vertical
plane at the shoulder and that's where
they get
injured. As she's trying to do this, she
never realizes that you're just hurting
yourself on the shoulder, but she
realizes it hurts. And now she hates
rolling even more and she doesn't want
want to do
it. So we have to fix the hip
alignment so that they learn how to not
stack on the
shoulder. And yet we're pro we're we're
making this or this is being made more
difficult for us because the newer
dashes goes unconscious when they get
topsyturvied.
So by giving
[Music]
them so to speak an awareness
handrail, we can have them maintain some
sort andor generate some sort of
awareness on where the hip is so that
they can stop stacking the
shoulders. That looks like this. This is
how we teach it. We start on the small
forward roll because they're going to in
they're injuring themselves. That is
what they're doing. They're injuring
themselves every rep. So, as I tell my
senpai here, do not spend all class
trying to get new people how to roll.
You do a little bit and you move
on. Tell them about tenderizing. A
polite way of saying you're injuring
yourself. We do small forward rolls
because there's less inertia from the
fact that there's not as much
gravitational force coming down.
This also helps them with their
unconsciousness because part of their
unconsciousness is that fear of falling.
So they're touching the mat. We let them
touch the
mat. We tell them to pay attention to
this line, this line with your front
knee and your front foot and your hip.
So, as they roll around, we want them to
trace their foot on the ceiling. That'll
guarantee that the knee stays in that
quad alignment as they're
going. And they come up like
this.
Again this way.
This was a
progression for somebody who is
still compromised by fear and subject to
moments of
unawareness. This is
not the
art. This is
counting. We have a problem and that is
the force equation. Mass times
acceleration equals force. What we're
trying to do is disperse mass off of
where the body makes contact with the
mat. By dispersing
force, there will by dispersing mass
there will be less force at those
points. As I already said, by lowering
the knee, like I said, we are decreasing
acceleration. And so our roles slow down
as they go. They don't speed up as they
go. And by slowing down as we go while
we're disseminating mass across the mat,
there's less force at impact. Now,
someone can actually pick me up off the
ground, throw me across the mat, and I
will not get hurt. If I pick up somebody
who's going to stack
mass, pick them up off the ground, throw
them across the mat, they're not going
to do that for very long, if even a
second time.
So, we throw them like that till they
get used to it in the next progression.
We let them do it. We don't do the X
patterns on them. Um, we don't do the
base displacements on them just to work
on these things, the fear, the
unconsciousness. But that's just a
progression, too. It's not an
application of the art. It's just
working on you.
Now we're trying to more tackle once
they got that we start tackling what
that math is. Force times force is mass
times acceleration. Let's start working
with that decreased force at impact.
Towards that end we have the feet going
out that way. And now we start to throw
a little
harder. That makes the feet go out that
way. And as I said, the person that
tries to do this progression will always
land on their hip. They just land on
their hip on a for on a front inward
kazushi. And they always have that
look because they still have the
unawareness. Okay, they're just waking
up. They didn't know what happened or
how they got there and they wake up at
the end of the
roll. I'm sure we have videos of that
where you could see the uk that
happening to them.
when we start speeding it
up. Aside from that, there is also a
very good reason on why you don't want
to do that anymore as the acceleration
increases from Nag. and that is that the
non rolling foot is going to slap on the
mat on this
part. So here I am doing that same
thing. We'll do it this
way. And as the non-rolling foot, boom,
it hits right there as it comes
around if you pay attention on the other
one. And that makes no sense. There's no
t there's no sport when anyone is trying
to walk
[Music]
on on that. There's no sport where
people try to walk on their insteps
because these are not
weightbearing
anatomical
elements. What we are doing now, and
I'll do it again slow, but you can slow
the video down and you will see it. I'm
going to have to game everything. But as
I take the other
geometry and my feet go
out, they're up off the
mat until I get here to the balls of my
feet, which is a loadbearing anatomical
element. Okay? And there's no risk of me
boom pounding
that outer ankle bone. Okay? So, we
either make the jump from these
progressions or we have set a limit on
how much of the art we can receive.
Meaning, we're not going to break you.
Or if we do break you, that's it for
your reception of the
art. You have to get past that
progression so that we can continue to
put the information into your body.
[Music]
You can see how the energy is
disseminating and the roll is slowing as
she goes.
She doesn't hit the side of her foot.
She finds her ball of foot at the
end. Easy peasy.